buen trabajo hasta ahora hemos definido
una curva que captura la variación del
brillo el brillo depende del eje o sea
la amplitud de la curva pero recuerda lo
que queremos es capturar los patrones en
resoluciones diferentes la primera curva
solo captura la variación en
resoluciones bajas piense en ella como
una pincelada gruesa así es que
necesitamos agregar variaciones con
resolución más alta estos son los
detalles más pequeños los cambios
pequeños en la amplitud para hacer esto
simplemente suma dos curvas por ejemplo
tomar la curva original y sumarse la a
la segunda curva nos quedará esta curva
final excelente matemáticamente sólo
estamos sumando las coordenadas 10 muy
bien hemos actualizado nuestro programa
para hacer una prueba en la parte
superior tenemos una curva de baja
resolución igual que en el ejercicio
anterior y debajo tenemos una curva que
se construye juntando dos copias de la
curva original es una curva con más
resolución porque contiene más detalles
llamémosle la curva de resolución media
y podemos seguir haciendo esto
aquí agregamos una tercera curva la
construimos juntando dos copias de la
curva de resolución media de la misma
forma esta es la curva de alta
resolución su variación es la más
detallada y hasta abajo mostramos la
suma de todas estas curvas
veo que también agregaste deslizadores
de amplitud que sofisticada si nos
permite ajustar cuánto contribuye cada
resolución a la curva final esto
significa que si el deslizador de
amplitud lo llevamos a cero esta
resolución es ignorada en la curva final
pero si lo subimos demasiado se nota
mucho su influencia por cierto este
proceso fue inventado porque en berlín
en 1988 y es por eso que esta variación
se llama ruido per link y su idea se ha
usado en casi todas las películas
generadas por computadora en los últimos
20 años
es tu turno de jugar con esto en el
próximo ejercicio vamos a ver que
también entendiste las curvas de
resolución múltiple y después lo podemos
estudiar en dimensiones más altas tienes
alguna anécdota sobre el ruido berlin
además de usarlo en los acabados de
superficie también usamos patrones de
ruido para controlar el peinado de los
cabellos usamos ruido perlín para
controlar la longitud de los cabellos el
grosor color y otros parámetros lo
puedes ver en casi todos nuestros
peinados en el cabello de spot en el
viaje de arlo este es un muy buen
ejemplo